Dude, the world is nuts. Like people thought like when Bieber challenged,
Tom cruise to the fight, like everyone was like, Oh, what the?
And then people was like, yo, I'm joking. And everyone, I mean, no.
He's joking, man. No. He's joking.
Bieber's like, yeah. Yeah. You're, you, you,
you want to fight or you're scared. You think talk.
You think Tom cruise would have beat up Justin Bieber?
I think just to be able to beat the out of him, people are like, yeah,
you don't with Tom cruise.
Or he does all his own stunts and he's always running.
I think beer will beat the out of Tom cruise.
And dude Bieber would have beat the out of Tom
cruise for real he's 20 zero.
And Tom cruise is 50 whatever.
And Tom cruise, uh,
would've would've would have sincerely lost and they would have interviewed
them.
So the fight in there, depending on people who,
when he would have been like publicly say, we have a responsibility,
it's not just the warnings. It's not just David Miscavige. You know,
it's not just not just me. It's.
That 75 times. Since the last time we talked about it,
my favorite is when he's like this, my favorite,
this is my favorite is when he goes like this and the end of it,
they get this clip of him just going like this. And he's just like,
and he does this. He does like what a straight up guy.
Who's just knows he's killing at life. And he's just like,
and he's got his one ring finger in his mouth and his other pinkie is just,
and he's just, and his two hands are up on the temple. Do it.
If you're doing that, you're this dude. He was gone. He goes like this.
Imagine doing that. That's some, dude,
if you put your two fingers up to your temple and your one finger in your mouth,
imagine this because some of you guys are just listening to this.
And then your little pinky is just dangling. Dude,
you got your two fingers on your temple. Imagine this one,
your ring finger on touching your bottom teeth.
And then your pinky is just dangling. Dude.
You cannot be more confident than that. You simply can't.
That part is so ill. There it is.
It's so ill.
I got to get to that point where you're just laughing about
life. That's what I love about Tom cruise,
that he laughed so much because his life is the.
His life is the.
There's nothing part of the way
or depending on us. There's nothing part of the way for me.
Cause I'm just joking about that. And it does make me feel that
we got more work. I need more help. I get those spectators.
You're in the playing field out of the arena. You know,
this is the guy I want to be. I understand. That's how I feel about it.
I do what I can do.
Tom cruise is saying for real it, this is his version of,
I want my chips with the dip.
I do it the way I do everything he does.
So not funny, but kill him part of the way
I do it. The way I do it.
Everything, there's nothing part of the way for me. I just,
and just die in dude, that you don't understand.
You don't understand. Dude.
People think that like Drake and like these famous people and
T Tom cruise, they just there that's. My goal
is to get there, dude is to get to the point where I'm just,
and by the way, I'm not that famous, but I'm almost there.
I'm the regular guy almost there. That's just like,
I'm on my chips with the DEP dude. I want to go to meetings and being like,
well, you know, I want my chips with the dirt
and just laughing like a dude of his.
That's not funny, but I don't give a because I'm killing it.
That's that's how you, that's how we all have to get. Dude.
If we aren't all there, then life is just going to crumble. Dude,
we're going to build these bombs. We're going to build these,
the cities are going to get too big people going to hate each other dude.
That's the goal to get there, dude,
to get there. I talk about this. This is a theme on this,
on this, on this, uh, on this podcast,
but it's the goal, dude.